you know what I realized something I
don't we were talking about this with my
buddies they were saying that they like
to put on [ __ ] music while they're
having sex and I think that that's I
don't think that that's I think that you
shouldn't listen to I think if you
listen to music while you [ __ ] that's
some real full-blown Kota [ __ ] for real
because dude it takes away from the
sexiness of it number one and I know
people will be like what it makes it
more sexy but it doesn't do first of all
if you're having sex with a girl you
kind of like and you put on some [ __ ]
lovely music you might fall in love
that's fake that's fake that's fake be
Ridge it's free conch you can put on
whatever you want but that's fake
alright another thing is if you're
trying to impress a girl and your [ __ ]
having sex with her and you put on some
NWA and you might [ __ ] and try and blow
her back out that's not cool either cuz
that's not how you are if you're not
listening to any music when you're
making love or doing it that's the [ __ ]
because then you get to hear all the
noises feel what it's really like and
[ __ ] experience the [ __ ] dude I'm
gonna have sex and listen to another guy
singing huh oh yeah let's have sex but
also let's involve other people no I
want to hear the [ __ ] I want to I
want to focus on the the kissing and the
touching and the thinking and the you
know come on [ __ ] while listening to
Josh Groban or Coldplay say yeah imagine
I mean you know I don't do that I don't
do that I don't listen that dude I had a
girlfriend once and she was like why
don't we never listen to music when you
have sex because that's a full-blown
khuda [ __ ] man I want to hear you know I
don't want to hear you know what the
sexiest thing to hear when you're having
sex is the daytime nothing sexier than
if you're having sex and you hear like
in the distance a lawnmower that's so
hot bro I'll immediately have an orgasm
if I hear a lawnmower
I'm having sex that's it way in the
background that's it that's the really
[ __ ] and then some chicks from bird just
like in the back you know this is so
real I'm a real person hurt oh god this
is real life part bird know like out
what the [ __ ] you want to hear the
[ __ ] Dana nano no nee-naw nee-naw
nee-naw nee-naw nee-naw nee-naw nee-naw
nee-naw nee-naw nee-naw no nano the [ __ ]
out of here so much cave so many piano
notes while you're thrusting massive a
yellow that's no [ __ ] Berber [ __ ] I'm
talking about lawnmower
[ __ ] you hear kids playing in a pool
[ __ ] 3 yards over forget it ultimate
explosion I'm looking it somebody in
their eyes while you hear a [ __ ]
trash van what do you call them trash
garbage trucks looking someone in the
eyes why you hear your garbage being
[ __ ] robot armed up into the hell
[ __ ] violent is it by the way when
you see those [ __ ] trash can't make
it smoother dude when it picks up the
thing and it's like good and it throws
up in the [ __ ] and your brain and
you're looking in a girl's eyes through
her soul dude
I'll tell you what man and you know what
another thing is that when you make love
there's no laughing bro there's no
laughing I don't give a [ __ ] if some
silly stuff happens you use it for the
seriousness of it you use it for the
seriousness of it look at how [ __ ]
violent it is and they miss all the time
- they [ __ ] miss all the time
I mean we got to show that on the
[ __ ] video podcast so don't give a
[ __ ] that's the guys the last day on the
job you know how violent are they listen
I can't even fit oh the so robotic make
it it's not ready yet
it's not ready yet these [ __ ] garbage
can got trash truck trash what do you
call garbage trucks not ready yet Oh
weird how jerky is that [ __ ] thing
look at how big it is
look at it
Oh can't get it it looks drunk why is
this on youtube you know garbage can't
man destroys trash bucket because it was
overfilled nothing's happening on the
robot arms look like they're coming
actually because they're so jerky
oh oh it's hilarious this [ __ ] guys
I'm watching a video where this oh you
[ __ ] it up dude what a dick that would
be me that would be me there's rules
dude if it's overfilled like that I over
fill my [ __ ] all the time I would ruin
it but but my point is nothing is sexier
than hearing the daytime when you're
making love night having sex at night is
not as cool having sex the sexiest time
to have sex 4:30 p.m.
thought about it I've thought about this
a lot 4:30 the Suns in the cool spot
where it might be peeking through the
blinds but you're inside someone and you
can hear kids playing in a pool forget
it forget it oh no you think a night
time is with a bunch of [ __ ] khuda
candles lit and the lights are out and
you're listening to [ __ ] you raise me
up or like by the way not knocking the
music call playing [ __ ] Josh Groban
awesome but listening to some Jack
Johnson with no shoes on that [ __ ]
guy
hey Jack Johnson put shoes on put socks
on put shoes on no why yeah
dolt oh and girls just love it he
doesn't wear shoes did you know that he
didn't he doesn't wear shoes oh really
cool see ya alright cool
oh oh oh he's poor guys [ __ ] got
millions of dollars put shoes on